it has been
1856 days since the 2016 presidential
election
we are now in the second week of the
12th month
of the year of our lord 2021
and still
hillary clinton is crying about losing
the 2016 election and i do not mean
crying in a figurative way
i mean she is literally tearing up
on television
reading the victory speech that she had
written
and intended to give but but never had
the chance to give
i didn't as you know write a concession
speech because even though we had a lot
of bumps those last 10 days
i i still thought you know we could pull
it out so i worked on
a speech that really
was about my journey and
had had a real emphasis on my mother's
life and journey as a way of you know
making it clear that yes i would be the
first woman president but i i like
everybody uh stood on the shoulders and
lived the
lives
and experiences of those who came before
us i dream of going up to her
and sitting down next to her
taking her in my arms
and saying look at me
listen to me
you will survive
you will have a good family of your own
and three children
and as hard as it might be to imagine
your daughter will grow up and become
the president of the united states
[Music]
that video is and i say this without
any exaggeration
the single funniest thing i have ever
seen it is so
perfect every single
thing about it
play it again
look at me
listen to me
you will survive
you will have a good family of your own
and three children
and as hard as it might be to imagine
your daughter will grow up and become
the president of the united states
[Music]
except she won't
she won't that won't happen ever
this is so
so sad so funny and so sad this is even
worse than that time that hillary
tweeted out a picture of herself on her
birthday and it was herself as a little
girl and it said happy birthday to this
future president but she lost the
republicans beat her just like
republicans are once again beating back
leftist politicians and policies in a
way that we have not seen
in years i'm michael knowles as the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from john chalmers who
says the masks are a reminder to be
afraid which is necessary to keep people
hypnotized that is a ridiculous a crazy
wild outlandish conspiracy theory that
is obviously just
demonstrably true
when you want to
not be hypnotized but when you want to
relax when you want to be able to loosen
up a little bit when you want to feel
good every
second of your working day i would
highly recommend you check out xchair
christmas is right around the corner and
you deserve a gift and even if you don't
deserve a gift well
it's the time for giving and charity and
so you know you should get one anyway
how about a gift that keeps on giving
you joy and comfort every day all year
long a gift that looks as good as it
feels
a gift that will actually pay for itself
in terms of how much more productive you
will be at work
i'm talking about
giving yourself the gift of an ex chair
i love my ex chair
the x chair is the most incredible piece
of furniture in this office okay it's
this amazing thing it's super cool and
modern looking it uh it's very
comfortable it keeps your posture very
nice it will massage you
it will either cool you down or warm you
up it is
if you want to get a massage in the
office and not worry about an hr
violation
check out exterior today here is x
cheers christmas gift for you save 100
off your extra by purchasing it at
xchairknowles.com
right now that is x the letter x
chair knowles
kwles.com exterior has a 30 day
guarantee of complete comfort you can
finance your purchase for as little as
30 bucks a month go right now to
xchairknowles.com and save externals.com
speaking of people not holding
public office hillary clinton she's out
she's never going to tearfully talk
about how your adult your daughter will
be the first female president she's not
that's not going to happen
also joe biden's nominee for uh
comptroller of the currency
also will uh not be holding that office
this woman's name is saul omarova do you
do you remember saul omarova we played
her testimony the other day i don't know
a few weeks ago on the show and how she
was grilled by republican senators
because she
has been and almost certainly still is a
communist i don't mean she is a democrat
i don't mean she supports welfare i mean
like an actual communist
with with degrees from places that bear
the names of of lenin and marx and that
kind of stuff so
biden nominated this commie to the the
office of the comptroller of the
currency
now she's out and the way that the new
york times phrased this
is that she's out because republicans
successfully
accused her of being a communist just
because she was born in the soviet union
it's bigotry it's xenophobia it's
nativist it's all of these things she
it's not her fault she was born
in
in the soviet union think of pope
benedict oh my god one of the greatest
men of the the 20th and 21st centuries
pope benedict happened to live in nazi
germany it's not his fault that he was
in just like it's not her fault except
the thing is
the problem with saul omarova is not
that she was was a communist when she
was a little kid it's that she she
remains a communist and pushes for these
policies even here in america even
within the last few years as
senator
kennedy
demonstrated during the testimony
you wrote your thesis in college at
moscow state university on the title was
karl marx's economic analysis
and the theory of revolution in the
capital
but you won't send senator toomey a copy
you studied at university at moscow
state university scientific communism
which is the science regarding the
working class struggle and the socialist
agenda
in 2019
not 30 years ago
in a canadian documentary you called
the financial services industry quote
a quintessential ass
industry
you wrote a paper called systemically
significant prices calling for the
federal government
to set wages food gas prices
in 2020 you wrote a paper called the
people's ledger
where you said we need to abolish bank
accounts and make everybody set up an
account at the fed would the federal
government have access to your data
senator kennedy just absolutely nails
this woman and and he did it in a a
really effective way that he in
particular is good at
the way that kennedy talks if you've
ever seen him on cable news for instance
is he'll talk in this really folksy way
so he'll go on tv and he'll say like
well you know there's three three ways
to skin a possum for dinner time and
well you know what my grandpappy told me
you know he talks in this folksy way but
he's extremely intelligent and extremely
educated and he kind of lures people in
so he did this with solomorova he opened
up he said were you part of some group
called the young communists
and she you know very condescending says
um no what are you talking about
whatever and then he goes and he says no
well you were because of you were at
this school and you wrote this paper and
you defended this policy and and she's
done this
even up to the last few years so we got
her
the takeaway here
is not even that joe biden's economy you
know or that their their left is pushing
all of these radicals we know that the
left is pushing radicals joe biden is
not a kami he's not really anything he
just licks his finger puts it up in the
air and figures out which way the wind
is blowing
the lesson here is persistence
okay the the left is very persistent
that's how they've taken over the whole
culture and when they lose on they just
send
they send the troops back in and they
just keep fighting and they keep pushing
and that has been very effective for
them
we can be persistent too
all right the left has shaped and
reshaped the limits of culture and
what's what you're allowed to say and
move the overton window we can do that
too
if we are just persistent ourselves
we say no
you can't you can't joe biden you know
you're just a vessel for
what whatever is politically convenient
you thought it was politically
acceptable to nominate a commie to this
position and it's not so we're we're
just going to say no and we're going to
hammer this woman until she withdraws
and she did withdraw and we actually can
win you're seeing this right now
even as we talk about overruling roe v
wade i mean that took 50 years almost
but but now it's at least possible
to do that got to be persistent speaking
of people's political stories falling
apart dr oz is running
as a
conservative republican for senate in
in pennsylvania and he says i'm a
conservative i'm a regular old like kind
of reagan-type conservative and i've
always been a conservative or whatever
well there's a clip that's just come out
of dr oz in recent years on the
breakfast club
uh seeming to
criticize to attack and to make fun of
the pro-life movement take a listen now
what are your thoughts on alabama and
these anti-abortion laws that they're
passing in alabama well that they've
passed is that healthy i'm i'm really
worried about it i'll tell you i i've
taken care of a lot of women who've had
issues around childbirth the problem
with the law is it stands now and i
think i think they'll always really only
pass to generate a supreme court
challenge
but most women don't know they're
pregnant
it's only it's two weeks past your last
period when you'll when you have to
decide by what yeah i i have people on
the show all the time who never know
they were pregnant even when they were
delivering 50 of women don't know
they're pregnant when they're pregnant
jesus so you're asking women to decide
almost instantaneously if they're
pregnant or not and they it's also
banned in case of incest and rape and so
uh i don't quite get it as a doctor and
the other thing is this whole thing
about heartbeating
i mean their electrical
changes at six weeks but the heart's not
beating
if you if you were if you were to say
starting from when we can hear the heart
like when the heart's really doing
something that'll be different
that's not six weeks though right so if
you can define life by a beating heart
then make it a beating heart not little
electrical changes in this in a cell
that's not that no one would hear would
think about as a heart
okay well dr oz doesn't think of a
baby's beating heart as a heart and i
don't think of dr oz as a conservative
or a republican so it's simple all right
and if you're going to nominate a
conservative or a republican to senate
how about you make sure that it's an
actual conservative or an actual
republican really really sad stuff from
a guy who look this is just the first
clip we're seeing in the days after he's
announced he's going to run for senate
and it doesn't look good it makes him
look very dishonest so i hope that dr oz
addresses that because otherwise
if uh
if if he thinks that the pro-life
movement is dead to him then dr oz is
dead to me that's how i feel
you know
you know what tastes really good dead
good american meat which is why i want
to encourage you to check out good
ranchers this christmas
give the gift of meat
yes meat really really good meat really
really high quality meat at the lowest
prices that you are going to find
anywhere a complete game changer i'm
talking about
good ranchers this is a box of 100
american meat that is steakhouse quality
goodranchers.com has a variety of boxes
to give or try for yourself gift gift
for yourself this season
you've got the rancher's classic for the
perfect combo of high quality beef and
tender chicken or you can go with the
cowboy to have the ultimate steakhouse
experience
with black angus rib eyes wagyu burgers
and more get 20 off and free shipping on
your order with my code knowles can wles
at checkout
this meat is just
better quality than the stuff you're
going to get at the grocery store and by
the way a lot of the stuff at the
grocery store even if it says product of
usa
most of the time it's not actually from
the usa it's just it's extremely
dishonest
get that good american meat get all your
individual and corporate gifts of good
ranchers today give a gift they'll
remember for years to come get your
goodrancher's box or gift card today tis
the season for open hearts and full
stomachs so give that good ranchers uh
to your friends code knowles for 20
bucks off and free shipping
goodranchers.com use codenoles at
checkout to take advantage of this offer
give good ranchers
speaking of public health figures
like dr oz
dr fauci
a much more powerful politician than
just some lowly senator dr fauci
is
now suggesting as we have been telling
you for weeks and weeks and months and
months
that fully vaccinated is it's probably
not going to be fully vaccinated forever
you know right now you are fully vac i
think you're still in america you're
fully vaccinated if you have one shot of
the johnson and johnson vaccine were two
shots of the mrna vaccine then you're
vaccinated and then we can go back to
normal right that's what they told us if
you just weigh the mask for two weeks
then we can go back to normal if you
just lock down for two years then we'll
just go back to normal if you just take
the shot with just go and then we never
go back to normal that's kind of that's
lucy with the football is we never
actually go back to normal so now dr
fauci is saying well you know two shots
is that really
enough no maybe we to be fully maybe
you'll need a third if you want to talk
about what optimal protection is i don't
think anybody would argue that optimal
protection is going to be with a third
shot whether or not it officially gets
changed in the definition i think that's
going to be considered literally on a
daily basis that's always on the table
always on the table because this and
this discussion has been going on for a
bit and i was just kind of with this
data coming in this morning
i'm kind of stuck with is it a matter
now of when
not if the definition of fully
vaccinated changes
you know my own personal opinion kate is
what you said is correct it's going to
be a matter of when not if
dr fauci is not known for his
consistency
right he says don't wear the masks masks
are dumb and then five seconds later he
says wear the mask you have to it's very
important what do you what he's not
known for his consistency
but he contradicted himself
in the same
breath in the same statement during that
segment he actually contradicted himself
initially he said look is the is the
official definition of fully vaccinated
ever gonna change to three shots i don't
know
maybe look it'd be good if you get three
yeah but i don't know if the definition
will change and then
the woman on tv says
well yeah but don't you think it's a
matter of when not if the definition
changes he goes yeah i do
bro you ju
just
15 seconds earlier you
you said that it wouldn't necessarily
change officially now you're saying it
will it's inevitable it's just a matter
of time
but if you don't believe dr fauci you're
denying science because he is the
physical embodiment of science which
changes apparently by the second
didn't know that
there's no end
to that dr fauci changed his mind
in the same breath and he's going to
change it again and he's going to change
it again and there's not going to be any
end to it and if you wear the masks
that's not going to help you get back to
normal and if you take the 10th booster
that's not going to help you get back to
normal and if you just lock down for a
few more it's not none of this none of
this is going to help you get back to
normal if you want to get back to some
semblance of normal society there's one
way to do it that will be more effective
than anything else and that is firing dr
fauci and banishing him to saint helena
that's your best shot and even then i'm
not sure you go back to normal
but certainly
appeasing this lunatic is not
going to help you do it
stop being charlie brown watching lucy
with
the football now
without you went on and there's never
any
shortage of hot air for dr fauci to blow
out of his mouth dr fauci went on to
castigate people who are not following
his every whim he says
it's it's long past time that we put
communal responsibility above individual
rights
in new york we're seeing the the mayor
introduce a vaccine mandate the first of
its kind for the private sector is this
the kind of mitigation tool that you see
in our future in your professional
opinion
you know francis we no one likes to be
mandating for people to do things that
they might be hesitant to do
but quite frankly you have to when
you're in the middle of what we call a
historic experience
of the worst pandemic of a respiratory
disease in the last 100 years
we have to put the communal
responsibility ahead of individual
preferences so although no one myself
included
likes to be told what you have to do
sometimes if you don't come to the
realization that it is good for yourself
for your family and for the communal
good
then mandates or requirements become
necessary so first of all this guy is
obviously lying through his teeth
nothing gives him a greater thrill than
telling people to do things they don't
want to do that is first of all his
entire
career that's his field right public
health
government bureaucrat public health is
the whole point of that is to tell
people on a huge scale what to do to
tell them to do things that they very
likely do not want to do and he loves it
and he gets a thrill out of it and it's
the high point of his career and
probably the high point of his life so
that part is dishonest but what about
the point dr fauci is making he's saying
that at a certain point you've got to
care about the good of the community
above the perceived rights of the
individual on that point
he's absolutely right
he's right he's right and a lot of
conservatives
don't get it a lot of conservatives
are
digging in their heels on this idea that
the common good the good of the
community
never can make any claims on my
individual rights whether they're real
or imagined but that's not true that has
no basis in conservatism that idea has
no basis in american history that has no
basis in the classical tradition it's
not i hate to say that fauci is right on
this point but he he is right in
principle
he's just wrong in practice the reason
that these actions are not justified the
locking down the taking all of this
power the upending our way of life the
indefinite
rule of the public health technocrats
the reason they're not justified is not
because the common good can never make a
claim on our individual rights the
reason they're not justified is because
the wu flu does not affect enough people
severely enough and the policies that
have been put in place are not effective
enough to justify it
i know that's a less satisfying answer
than some really cheap shallow
ideological point that you can write on
the back of a napkin but that's the
reason
it's not even the principle it's the
particulars
if the
black death broke out in the united
states
i guess now you'd have to call it death
of color because black death would not
be politically correct if the bubonic
plague broke out in the united states
and let's say it was a disease even
worse than the bubonic plague and we
didn't have treatments and 80 percent of
the country were dropping dead and were
highly transmissible
are you you're seriously telling me that
the public health bureaucracy would have
no right to prioritize the common good
and
saving the american people over certain
individual rights of course they would
have that right of course they would
have certain emergency powers and of
course the common good is a real thing
that we see referred to in
the constitution of the united states
for one in the preamble that we see
referred to in
so many of the founding documents and
that we see referred to in all serious
political philosophy now of course they
would have that claim
but this ain't it
the infection fatality rate for the
wuhan virus is extremely low
and when you take out very specific
groups
elderly people people who are extremely
unhealthy
then the infection fatality rate drops
even
lower point zero zero five percent in
some cases point zero zero three percent
for some groups
the the
median age of a covid death
for much of this epidemic we'll call it
whatever you want
has been higher than the life expectancy
in the united states
so
obviously there are specific groups that
need to be protected but for most people
it's not as huge a deal and the
mitigation measures by the way that have
been put into place have not been as
effective as the libs told us they would
be
up to and including the vaccines which
is why we're now talking about how we
need a third shot and a fourth shot and
booster after booster after booster
which you would not need obviously if
the vaccine were more effective or as
effective as we were told it was in the
first place it's the particulars not the
principle we should focus on
the the left's principles are very often
bs2 you can see this down in virginia
right now so there's a famous statue
of general robert e lee this
statue stood in charlottesville virginia
a lot of the protests on the left and
the right in charlottesville a few years
ago in 2017 came about as a result of
this effort by the left to tear down a
statue of robert e lee now what what the
conservatives said at that time is no
matter
what you think of the south no matter
what you think of
robert e lee even who was actually a
very noble guy might have fought for a
bad cause but very noble guy
we shouldn't be tearing down history
like this and the point of having these
kinds of statues and the point of of
having some recognition of southern
heritage is that we fought this bloody
civil war but then america came back
together with malice toward none and
charity for all in the words of abraham
lincoln and so we shouldn't undermine
all of that and say that the south is
this evil awful terrible place that's
completely irredeemable don't do that
don't erase history and the libs told us
no we're not a racing history we're just
gonna we're gonna tear it down but we're
gonna put it in a museum
and i guess that's true we've just found
out though before they put it in the
museum they're going to melt the statue
down
into liquid metal and then sculpt it
into something else but they're not a
racing history they say you know
one thing that you ought to erase is
your unnecessarily high mortgage
payments which is why i would strongly
recommend you check out american
financing what if you could lower your
mortgage rate without adding years to
your loan potentially saving hundreds of
dollars a month and tens of thousands
long term well fortunately for you
it is possible when you call american
financing america's home for home loans
you will start with a free mortgage
review from one of their salary-based
mortgage experts so you can understand
all of your home loan options from
flexible terms to competitive rates and
fast closings they have got you covered
you really can save up to a thousand
dollars a month with these guys and you
can choose any term 10 years and over
custom loans do not get any better than
this so what are you waiting for make
the 10 minute no obligation call right
now learn the options get these savings
as soon as possible that's 800 658 56 96
what's that number
number is 800 658 5696 or if you are
more digitally inclined go to
americanfinancing.net
nmls 182 334 nmls consumeraccess.org
so far the daily wires lawsuit against
the biden vaccine mandate is working
it's working extremely well not only has
the osha mandate received a nationwide
stay it's not being put into effect this
week a federal court enjoined the biden
administration
from
enforcing its federal contractor vaccine
mandate as well this is great news but
we need your help if you have not signed
our petition against joe biden's vaccine
mandate i need you to head on over to
dailywire.com do not comply to add your
name we have a goal of reaching one
million signatures and we have nearly
three quarters of a million signatures
so far we need your help to cross the
finish line please head on over to sign
the petition at dailywire.com do not
comply then share the petition with all
of your friends and family and then go
buy matt walsh's book mount walsh is not
only a beloved best-selling children's
author but he is the number one
best-selling lgbt author in america
which is just terrific so go get his
masterpiece johnny walrus today we'll be
right back with a lot more
the libs told us that they are not
tearing down statues to destroy them or
to topple history they are doing it
to change the public spaces to be more
reflective of the society we are today
but they're going to keep all those
statues in museums right
and some of us
hate to say i told you so knew that was
bs
wasn't a great idea to begin with and it
was not going to really happen so now
we're finding out that the statue of
robert e lee from charlottesville is
going to be uh
donated to an african-american heritage
organization we're not sure which one
what the group is
and then it will be melted down and
turned into another public piece of art
all that they told us about not
destroying history is bs this is a
full-on cultural revolution that is
designed to topple every single thing
that we have known to be america they're
not going to stop with the south or the
confederacy or robert e lee they're
going to go on and already have gone on
to washington and jefferson and u.s
grant the union general and abraham
lincoln who freed the slaves it doesn't
matter they want to topple and destroy
and melt down to its very essence every
single thing that has ever been
recognizable as
american
this is a really good symbol it's a
really sad thing but it's a really good
symbol
melting down
and transforming into something else
entirely that that is the leftist
project maybe you've heard about these
academic movements from the late 20th
century deconstruction we're going to
deconstruct
everything we're going to we're going to
break it down let's break this down
right
well this is the logical conclusion of
deconstruction and this is the point of
deconstruction you break everything down
to its most basic bits
and then you reform it into something
else
this is how
[Music]
revolutionaries work this is a very
effective political strategy this is
what the the united states military does
right so it can be used to good purpose
you ever hear this about the marines
other marines they'll take you in and
they'll break you down and they'll build
you back up and that's the point they
want to
take whatever deformities you have break
those down and then form you into a
marine into this great strong patriotic
fighting force well that's what all
revolutions are doing they break things
down and then they reform it their own
image
can't make an omelet without cracking a
few eggs
right that's what we are seeing
happen
now so if you want
to preserve anything resembling america
you need to say no to all of this and
you need to not fall for it and you need
to not be a squish who says well i look
i'm a northerner and obviously i don't
like the confederacy and i don't so i
don't like robert e lee and so you can
have robert e lee that's fine i don't
care yeah that's cool i'm good i'm not
racist i'm not racist don't call me
racist i'm that's fine
no it's not it's not about robert e lee
dummy
it's not about the confederacy it's
about america it's about america it's
about lincoln and washington and you
it's about you it's about any
aspect of america that you hold on to
they want to melt it down okay and
reform it into some radical leftist
monstrosity that uh
if you know anything about modern art
you know it's not too pretty okay don't
do it don't let them do that to your
entire country speaking of cultural
revolutions
the european union is is trying to erase
christmas
it's that time of year it's time for the
war on christmas it happens every year
the libs deny it even as they wage it i
have a long chapter in my book about the
history of the war on christmas it's
extremely real
and the people who deny that the war on
christmas is real they will often say
the war on christmas is totally fake
it's not real and it's not a big deal
it's totally fake it's not happening but
it is happening and it's not a big deal
well no it is happening and it is a big
deal
so in in some guidance titled union of
equality this was just leaked from the
european union
the eu advised to quote avoid assuming
that everyone is christian during the
christmas season
the eu equality commissioner
helena dali
advised staff not everyone celebrates
the christian holidays and not all
christians celebrate them on the same
dates we'll get to that in a second
instead of saying christmas time you
should say holiday times
you know holiday times like for all
those holidays that there are well what
are the holla what are the holidays
during christmas season there is kwanzaa
which is completely fake just completely
fake invented by a uh a woman torturing
sadistic socialist in the 1960s some
flunky professor from cal state long
beach who his name was uh what ron
kalenga
is he that's not even i don't think
that's his full name but then he called
himself melania karanga and he's just a
complete psychodegenerate so there's
that which is celebrated by virtually no
one there's i guess there's hanukkah
which is a minor holiday even for jews
right it's not a major holiday even for
jews
and there's
uh
there's the feast of the immaculate
conception that was yesterday somebody
tells me that's not what the eu is
referring to there are there's winter
solstice for the like five pagans out
there i don't that's not real um
oh it's christmas it's just christmas
that's the holiday
okay but we have to deny that
we don't deny other hot but we have to
deny christmas and make everything
secular the guidelines also say that
members of the eu should avoid using
names like maria and john that originate
in christianity and instead use
multicultural options such as i'm not
joking
malika and julio
so you can't europe cannot refer to
maria and john
they have to refer to
malika and julio okay
the reason i mention this story is that
pope francis who is
often painted as a liberal at least if
not an outright communist in the public
media
pope francis has just come out and said
this is terrible
he he referred to it as an anachronism
of watered-down secularism he said in
history many many dictatorships have
tried to do this sort of thing think of
napoleon from there think of the nazi
dictatorship think of the communist one
christmas is christmas it's not just
some secular holiday and it's
preposterous to pretend that it is you
see the same thing now with the libs
they have tried to get rid of the
the phrase bc and a.d to refer to time
before christ and anno domini the year
of our lord they've tried to get rid of
that
but they use all the same numbers so now
instead of saying this such and such
happened in
253 bc they'll say it happened in 253
bce
before the common era
and then they'll instead of a d they'll
say c e commonair but it's referring to
the era of christianity so it's just a
joke
it's it is
christian
you can't
europe is christian
europe is a christian it certainly was
christian i think it still has a lot of
christianity to it whatever we refer to
as europe
is christian so you if you get rid of
the christianity you get rid of the
europe you can't have all the stuff
you can't have all the trappings of
christianity but then pull christ out of
it it's not going to work it's not going
to work for a very long time
secularization is not only bad it's
extremely stupid it can't happen
we try to do this in america we say look
you don't need religion to be moral or
spiritual you know look we just look
we're just good people we just know that
we should love our neighbor as ourselves
and love the lord our god above all
things we just know
that we need to follow the ten
commandments we just know that we need
to
treat one another in the ways that were
developed over millennia of christendom
we just know it we know that there are
truths that are self-evident that all
men are created equal and endowed by
their creator with certain unalienable
rights including life liberty and
pursuit of happiness we just know that
why do we know that dum-dum we know that
we know that because of christianity
that's where that comes from so you
can't
if you take guidance if you take the
creator of all things and the legislator
of the moral law and the great moral
order if you take him away
then you lose the moral order too you
lose all of it
why why do we how do we know that we're
endowed with unalienable if there's no
creator to endow us with them how do you
know we're endowed with rights to life
liberty and the pursuit of happiness you
don't it's just fake
why be good if we're all just worm food
if we're all just walking worm food who
think that we're alive because of some
pistons randomly firing in our brain if
life is a tale told by an idiot full of
sound and fury signifying nothing then
what does it matter
it doesn't it doesn't mean anything if
there's no meaning in the world then
certainly there's no human rights
certainly there's no natural rights
there's not good or bad but thinking
makes it so so
so what happens to civilization it
doesn't make any
sense
great stuff from the pope great stuff
you know
people criticize the pope when he says
things that are a little strange but
he's absolutely right on this point
speaking of christmas did you know
that the fox news christmas tree caught
fire in manhattan it just caught fire
like i don't know i guess someone was
pitching some fire and it caught it
right that's what that was the new york
times headline
fox news christmas tree catches fire in
manhattan
now they've since changed the headline
because it got so much flack
trees don't just catch fire generally
usually someone lights them on fire as
was the case at fox
at fox
someone went up on 6th avenue and let
the tree on fire because they don't like
fox news presumably
just like how suvs don't
don't drive themselves into christmas
parades
they are driven by people
just like guns
don't
just randomly kill people in chicago
we've got a gun problem in chicago we've
got to stop these guns it's not guns
it's criminals those are that's who's
killing people in chicago
it's
criminals driving the suv it's criminals
setting the
tree on fire but the libs won't admit
that
the libs are happy to assign blame and
guilt even when it's not real
uh if it fits their narrative like kyle
rittenhouse who shot people in
self-defense who were trying to kill him
they said he's an awful terrible
murderer who needs to be thrown in the
clink forever
but when it comes to
and and that turned out not to be true
and written house was exonerated but
when it comes to their own guys it's
just the inanimate objects there's a
real epidemic
of inanimate objects springing to life
and committing crimes isn't there and
speaking of burning things down at
christmas i have to get to this
because it drives me crazy
speaking of christmas time speaking of
the pope mentioning that this is a
christian
holiday and a christian moment there is
a myth there is a legend out there that
christmas started out as a pagan
festival and then the early christians
kind of just said out of nowhere that
jesus was born on december 25th to to
co-opt a pagan festival and to to trick
all the pagans into becoming christian
that's that's the legend a ton of people
believe it and it is just completely
fake there is no evidence for it
whatsoever there is not a shred of
evidence that christmas december 25th
began as a pagan
holiday we are told alternately that it
began as the feast of saturn or the
saturnalia or it began as the feast of
the unconquered sun soul invictus or it
began
as a feast for mithras another sort of
pagan feast it's just
not true saturnalia was celebrated on
december 17th started around 200 bc
it
then was extended over time to last an
entire week ending on december 23rd
it never had anything to do with
december 25th so the connection is
supposed to be because the feasts are
near to one another but at least at the
beginning the
christmas feast was well over a week
later
okay
then we've got
uh what's the next one
oh yes soul soul invictus so soul
invictus and mithras we are told that
because of the the feast of the
unconquered sun and the feast of mithras
they happened around that time that
therefore christianity was or christmas
rather was taken from that it's not true
so the
the earliest text we have to tell us
about when these feasts were is
something called the chronography of 354
and it shows christmas being celebrated
it shows solo and vic is being
celebrated on december 25th it also
shows christmas being celebrated on
december 25th so there's no evidence
that one came before the other it may
well be the case that the feast of sole
invictus was put there to counter the
spread of christianity it might be the
case that christmas was there first the
reason that december 25th was chosen is
because of its connection to good friday
to the crucifixion the idea is that
it was commonly held uh at in
the first and second century that a
divine before that that a divine life
would be perfect so there would be a
connection from conception to death and
so because christ dies
on good friday
then christ must have been conceived on
good friday and what happens nine months
after good friday christmas which by the
way shows you that these early
christians believe that life begins at
conception as well just just a little
brief interlude in our discussion of
politics and are laughing about hillary
clinton
and are talking about all the things
that are going on on capitol hill to
remind you that there are a lot of these
legends that are bogus they are
anti-christian they are trying to do as
pope francis observes they're trying to
secularize everything and erase
christianity from public square and it's
just bs
do not
believe it do not believe that at all
there are a lot of myths in our politics
a lot of legends here's here's one of
the most predominant
myths today
that on january 6 a day that will live
in infamy on january 6 the terrorist
insurrectionists
almost
conquered the united states
thomas
conover
remember that name thomas conover
of texas
he was one of the insurrectionists
from january 6. so he's on trial now
and there
well evidence from his trial is now
coming out photographs of him that day
photographs of him smiling thumbs up
sipping a coors light yes that's right
remember that face
remember that face of that terrorist
the man that that logger sipping monster
who nearly brought the global hegemon to
its knees does he if you're watching
this right now
does this guy look like the kind of
person who's going to bring the world's
superpower crumbling down
or does he look like a
sort of excited and eccentric
political activist who made it into the
capital was was up to such surreptitious
sedition
seditious activities that he was taking
photos
sipping his coors light
and then he sort of left
he's been charged he's been charged not
with drinking watered-down beer he's
been charged with four misdemeanors
including entering restricted grounds
disorderly conduct and unlawful protest
in the capital he has not yet entered a
plea
the libs did not want us to see these
photos
the libs
wanted us to believe that this was a
well-organized terrorist group that went
in armed to the hilt they weren't armed
by the way but that they were armed to
the hilt and they were killing people
and killing cops and taking over the
country didn't happen the only person
who was killed in the political violence
was one of the
right wingers was ashley babbitt who was
killed by a cop
air force veteran ashley babbitt
they didn't want us to see these photos
because the photos contradict the
narrative you can't look at these photos
and say this was
the insurrection to take down the
country it wasn't
might have been eccentric people
might have been disorderly
maybe they deserve to be charged with
these misdemeanors or whatever you know
what they don't deserve to be thrown in
solitary confinement for months and
months on end you know what they don't
deserve to be called traitors and
seditionists and terrorists
because they manifestly are not those
things
so the best they've got
disorderly conduct unlawful protest in
the capital
how many libs have done that
in just the last
five ten years
how many times has there been some group
of crazy libs whether it was the pink
shirt ladies or the pink hat ladies or
what the left wingers breaking and
screaming interrupting senate testimony
into breaking into how many times has
that happened countless times just in my
own life
but but they face very few consequences
if any and then the conservatives who do
it the right wingers who do it get the
book thrown at them this is what is so
wrong about what's going on with january
6th is it's not that the the january 6
people didn't do anything wrong i guess
it's probably not legal to sip a course
outside right that's probably not
legal either
it's not that it's completely innocent
people in on completely made-up charges
it's that it's people who are in on
extremely trumped-up charges
that's why they're the nearest thing to
political dissidence that we have in the
united states and the libs have to keep
up this narrative that their got when
their guys burn down the country for six
months that's good they're mostly
peaceful protesters and when
a dude shows up sipping a coors light
taking pictures in the capital rotunda
he's a terrorist who should be sent to
guantanamo bay speaking of the lib
narrative breaking down
more bad news for kamala harris
a uh a new poll out from rasmussen says
that a majority of voters do not believe
that kamala harris has what it takes to
be president
not a majority of republicans not a
clear majority of all voters
55 quote don't think the vice president
is qualified for the top job
46 so almost half the country
says that she is not at all qualified
not not even like a little bit
40
of voters believe that harris does have
the traits to become president
and 23 say that she's very qualified
so you got
40
not qualified they're 40 they qualified
55 say
not qualified
i guess 5 very confused
why do people think this what the libs
are telling us
is that people have this negative view
of kamala harris including many many
democrats
because she's a woman she's a woman of
color she's indian and port jamaican i
think even though i think she's
descended from slave owners as her dad
said and i'm not you know but whatever i
don't i don't want to play the game the
identity politics game that's why
she is disliked
that's why people don't think she's
qualified no do you know why people
don't think she's disqualified why
people of all political stripes of all
geographical locations of all colors of
all races all they don't think she's
qualified because she's not because it's
true because
no matter how
much the libs push their
fictional narrative
people
tend to have a sense of what is real and
what is fake and what is true and what
is false and you can really try to
suppress it and you can try to melt it
all down and you can try to rebuild it
into something else and it's just it's
still going to be there because we still
have human nature we still have reason
we still have moral conscience
and there is
nothing
that kamala harris can do about it
speaking of the pope speaking of sins of
the flesh
and then
then going back to talk about the pope
pope francis this is like defend pope
francis day even though i know he says
lots of things that seem a little
strange or wrong or perhaps you're
heretical he he's getting in trouble for
saying something that is just obviously
true he was
paraphrased by reporters saying that
sins of the flesh are bad but they're
not the worst sins
that's true
that's true what he said
sins of the flesh are bad but this is
it's obviously true that sins of the
flesh you know you do some weird sex
thing or something they're obviously not
the worst things this has been
understood since the earliest days of
christianity dante describes this very
clearly in in his poem in inferno and in
in the whole divine comedy sexual sins
are bad and and they're probably the
ones that ensnare people the most
uh if there's a marian apparition that i
happen to believe is true that's called
our lady of fatima where it was said
that uh more people are in hell because
of sins of the flesh than any other sin
that's probably true you know you think
of the sins that especially for dudes
the things that really grab you tend to
be sins of the flesh
but they're far from the worst there's
fraud there's betrayal there all these
sorts of sins can be much much worse and
so
you want to
you want to
avoid sin advice and all those things
generally but there are worse things
such as
deception such as fraud
which dante puts in the lowest circles
of hell and
to me that's the real political scandal
okay and it's the one
we always talk about political scandals
as if they're just about sex no
dishonesty fraud
the the deceitfulness that's what the
big issue is and that that is probably
the biggest political problem plaguing
our nation and that's the one that we've
got to fight back against and see
through the most i'm michael knowles
this michael known show see you tomorrow
look at me
listen to me
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
john bickley here daily wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our
show morning wire where we bring you all
the news that you need to know in 15
minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia hal for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire